coucou
sur tik tok que je vois plein de
professionnels de la petite enfance qui
nous donne plein conseil j'ai une petite
question
le terrible tout ça dure combien de
temps s'il vous plaît parce que voilà il
faut que je me prépare psychologiquement
ça fait déjà un petit moment que ça dure
et elle n'a pas encore deux ans voilà
donc je je crains le pire donc s'il vous
plaît
sauvez moi
tu sais tu peux me dire c'est en les
contournant par casser avec ça t'es pas
obligé de m'envoyer des petits messages
subliminaux
allait bien on va chasser le sanglier
ont vx
[Musique]
cotation
ont été appelés
et
le monde sait ça y est vous avez dit que
j'arrêterais un producteur je pense que
le moment est venu de vous le présenter
je veux dire oui à venir commenté m oui
moi fais moi c'est partir le coup de
foudre pour cette jeune fille action
d'enfants ménage tient talent fou une
connaissez j'ai beaucoup d'artistes à
des garets et je veux absolument
travailler avec cette fille lui donner
un petit peu de mon expérience pour
habiller son talent parce que je vous
jure qu'elle a un talent exceptionnel
alors on va travailler ensemble on va
monter un spectacle comme on va mettre
du temps pour jouer parce qu'il faut
vraiment que ça soit bien on va essayer
de trouver quelque chose d'original pour
qu'elle mette en valeur toutes ses
qualités d'imitatrice et le chanteuse et
on va travailler ça pendant tout l'été
ensemble
elle a créé
et
oui
[Musique]